hello everyone and welcome to the
bindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll as we go through life one of the
things that we're inevitably going to do
all the time is to assign credit or
blame
for things that happen in the world
either to people or to other events that
are happening right we have effects
things that happen and we have the
causes for those effects the reasons why
those things happen this idea of a
structure of reality based on causes and
effects and their relationships is
perfectly obvious right i mean it's
something that is completely evident to
us ever since we were little kids the
ancients talked about it aristotle
famously kind of organized a whole
categorization of causes and different
kinds of causes and their effects but
like many such ideas when you think
about it a little bit more deeply it
becomes tricky what exactly is going on
if i say i got sick because of a virus
what do i really mean i mean there's a
kind of simple answer which is if it
weren't for the virus i wouldn't have
gotten sick right the virus weren't
there but you try to implement that in
some systematic way and what you find is
it's it's much trickier than that for
example what if you had gotten the virus
but you were also vaccinated so
therefore you were protected against it
or what if you didn't get the virus but
you got something else so you got sick
anyway
furthermore that kind of reasoning isn't
limited to just the virus right i mean
darwin's theory of evolution is
responsible for viruses in the first
place in some sense so did you get sick
because of darwin's theory of evolution
did you get sick because space-time is
four-dimensional without which maybe
there wouldn't be such thing as viruses
it's hard to pin down exactly what's
going on and this difficulty is not just
for physicists or philosophers or other
kind of scientists it's becoming
increasingly important in artificial
intelligence research because computers
don't have this immediate obvious
feeling that there are causes and
effects in the world like human beings
do so we really do need to get at the
guts of what's going on when we talk
about causes and effects and modern
scientists and philosophers and
mathematicians and computer scientists
have done this no one has been more
influential than today's guest judea
pearl he's done foundational research on
understanding what is meant by causes
and effects and he's written about it he
has a popular book from a few years ago
2018 with dana mckenzie called the book
of why the new science of cause and
effects you can read about it there but
you can also get it here on this podcast
so we're going to talk about exactly
this set of questions just to give you a
little bit of a hint the idea is we
think about probabilities of things
happening and even if there's definite
things that happen even if it's not
about randomness maybe you don't know
what's happening right so for a
statistician if you say there are people
a set of things called people and some
of those people drink alcohol and some
tea total some don't drink alcohol so
what that will mean is there's a
fraction of the people who drink and
that's saying that the probability that
a randomly selected person will drink is
a known quantity so there's a
probability involved even if everything
is perfectly deterministic and then also
for people there's a probability that
they own a cat or own a dog or have no
pets at all or both or whatever and then
you can ask questions about well okay
given that you drink or you don't drink
what is more likely do you own a cat a
dog or no pet at all and then you can
say what causes what are people who
drink more likely to own pets or if you
own a cat does that force you to drink
that's the kind of question that this
new science of causality is designed to
answer i'm not going to give away all
the ways that it happens but again
crucially important for computer science
and artificial intelligence also for
areas like medicine you want to know
what medical intervention is giving some
effect in the patients for politics or
economics what policy changes lead to
what effects this idea of cause and
effect in getting it right pervades how
we think about the world as a physicist
of course there's a whole other dialogue
to have about the fact that in newton's
laws of motion there are no causes and
effects so how do you recover them at
the macroscopic level we get into that a
little bit and many more interesting
ideas so let's go
[Music]
judea pearl welcome to the mindscape
podcast
i'm glad to be here so
causality is one of my favorite topics
to think about both as a human being and
as a academic researcher so this is
gonna uh be a great thrill for me to
talk to the world's master let's you
know try to get on the table how
the typical person out there should
think about causality you know we'll
hear we're both right now in los angeles
as we're recording this
we'll hear people say things like i was
late because there was a traffic jam on
the 405
attributing to the fact that they're
late a cause namely there's a traffic
jam of on the 405. so
i guess the first question is does that
make sense are these good ways of
thinking is that is that cause that's
the best way because that's the way
people talk
and
to distinguish
my
profession or my hobby from yours
i'm interested in capturing the way
people think and not the way nature is
constructed
so this is because i am in the
circle of ai people
and we have a certain mission
we want to capture how you and i think
so that the robot can communicate with
that in a natural way
regardless of how the molecules move
and i think it's a great fact that ai
helps us understand not only the world
but how we think because we take so many
things for granted right and the
computers don't
absolutely and that is a real test and
that's why as i'm accused many times
that i didn't pay attention to the great
philosophers to what
can't say than a hegel and aristotle
well
they didn't have a pressure
to
build a robot that behaved like us
and they didn't have a metaphor of
thinking
that's important yeah so explain what
more what do you mean by that the
metaphor of thinking
well
the cart had a metaphor we have gears in
our mind
and they turn and that's what makes us
deduce one thing from another okay right
but
why
he needed to have a metaphor because he
was familiar with gears
he wasn't familiar with neurons
he wasn't familiar with even um
logic circuits
he had only one metaphor
for
um
a deductive machine or at least a
machine that has output based on input
and that was the gears system that
archimedes may be invented right so he
put it together once you have a i call
it's a laboratory or playground right
you have to have a playground for your
own ideas
so you can take them apart and try
different combinations so philosophers
did not have a playground for ideas
about thinking
so they and we have we have the
computers are forcing
and that is why i i don't see that i can
learn much from philosophers good
perfectly fair now i will mention
aristotle once and not because i learned
a lot from his
theories of causation but because you
know he did sort of try to divide up
different kinds of causes and i think he
went too far into things that we don't
even call causes but let me just
distinguish between the kind of thing i
said i was late because there's a
traffic jam
versus something like why is the sky
blue well it's blue because short
wavelengths of light scatter off of air
preferentially but that's not an event
right i mean the traffic jam is an event
in space time the properties of the air
are properties that are more or less
permanent are are those the same kind of
cause effect relationships from your
point of view or do you distinguish
between those we distinguish between
them okay one is called the
actual cause
and i think philosopher called it a
token
okay token versus
i forgot the
other one talking
type
okay one is based on variable yeah and
the other one is based on event right if
you say
i was late because of the traffic jam
okay i'm i'm talking about one specific
event
in one specific time
in one individual that's me
and one situation okay that's talking
and this
one event caused another one
and the
the
contrast to that
is um a variable based causation like
the careless driving cause accident okay
which means it's in
the variable
the driving type okay uh which has many
values depending on how you drive okay
and then tends to
cause
a higher risk of accidents
the philosopher used the example of
drinking hemlock caused death or
socrates died because he drank this
hemlock
that this is a different that's a
singular singular versus token okay
that's how they use it right okay and so
we have different name for them and we
have different algorithms for
identifying each one good
and do you think that
causality is something that is
fundamental in nature or is it something
that is helpful to be human beings to
describe what's going on in nature is it
more emergent or is it built in to the
fabric of reality
there's nothing there's no cause and
effect in physics as you know it
because all the the equations of physics
are symmetrical in time
so
they are built around
algebra algebra is taught to a
connective called equality and equality
is symmetric so if f is equal to m a
then a is equal to f
over m okay
this
physics doesn't distinguish between the
two however as an emergent property
we perceive certain things
as um
as directional right we say that the
rooster crow does not call the sunrise
but the other way around even though it
occurs earlier and is highly highly
correlated
i will i will be forced sometimes to ask
questions that i think i know the answer
to just because it will help the
audience along so don't be surprised
no no no no i like those because it
gives me a chance to repeat myself
that's good we'll both be doing that
okay
so no i mean i like this distinction
that you're drawing and i just want to
emphasize how very profound it is right
i mean there was this giant revolution
with newton and descartes and galileo in
constructing
mathematical theories of physics and
you're right the most commonly appearing
symbol in a mathematical equation set of
mathematical equations is the equal sign
right and there's no arrow on it and so
in some sense you're doing something
absolutely audacious
or at least going back to a previous
time when these audacious things were
commonplace when you're saying i want to
know not just equal signs but arrows
which is the cause and which is the
effect yeah correct i'm glad that you
share with me
the
astonishment or the uh
about what galileo did yeah that each it
shows algebra and say nature speaks
algebra
which wasn't clear at the time
and
it enabled him to do so many things that
weren't done before
just 50 years after the invention of
algebra by vietnam
right
okay
i i i think people the students today
should appreciate this revolution
and
and take analogy now that draw parallel
to what civil rights did
civil right is a geneticist in 1920 that
got sick and tired of working with the
equation and said it doesn't represent
what i want
i want to have an assignment operator
i put an arrow he didn't think about
assignment but we in computer science
know that there is a difference between
assignment yeah and the equality okay
i i take the content of register a
and assign it to be the content of
register b okay it's a different
operator
which says it's
asymmetric
and it's ripped and he was the first to
put a symbol for his the symbol was an
arrow and he built these path diagrams
which everybody attacked him for that
but at least he said it represents what
he wants
right and before okay so that's why i i
admire him
for being for having the audacity to put
a new symbol for something
that he understood is needed
and
i'm trying to understand because so all
right we're done with the questions that
i think i know the answers to now we're
already moving on to questions i don't
know the answers to uh what is the
relationship of this new way of thinking
which again it's an old way of thinking
right aristotle would have been
perfectly happy with these arrows but we
sort of got rid of them and we're
bringing them back um what is the
relationship between this and the idea
of counterfactuals or possible worlds i
mean a very simple-minded
guess as to what causes r is that a
causes b if
had a not happened b would not have
happened and so already you're talking
about a whole different universe where
different things happen
right and that was the
a glitch of hume
he used almost this term had a not
happened b would not have yeah
what's the relation is that we have a
calculus of counter factor very simple
which means
we put
we take path diagram
the way that
c will write put them on
and we can define
what a
counter factor is for every two
variables of every two events we can
assign truth value to every counter
factor you can can think of based on
the path diagram so that
we have a calculus plus we have
an understanding of what you need to
build those path diagram
and it's built on one
relationship listen to
right
everything is built on knowledge you
have to
combine data with knowledge so somebody
has to build those path diagram
what do you need to think of
when you decide whether to put an arrow
or not to put an error between a and b
that is the question what it comes to
your mind
and the only primitive we need is the
primitive of listens to okay the
barometer deflection listens to the
atmospheric pressure
the rooster listens to the glare in the
sky
okay that
okay that's only relationship
it's a very primitive one
and it's a very natural one because i
believe this is the most rudimentary if
you're not asked for more rudimentary
and simple relationship for a scientist
or for a robot to think about
the barometer example is a very good one
we think that you know the barometer is
telling us the atmospheric pressure and
if all we had
was the data if all we knew was what the
pressure was and what the barometer meat
reading was
we're back in galileo land and there's
an equal sign and there's no arrow going
either way and and what you're saying is
there's something extra that that is
missing it's not just a correlation
there is a clear fact of the matter that
the
pressure is causing the barometer not
the other way around and that's what we
would like to understand yeah
and we only come aware of it
when we have to program on a stupid
robot
because the stupid robot if you look for
the equation we will try to move the
barometer
and hope to see us to prevent the rain
tomorrow okay right good and and let me
also just give the audience a visual
here because uh you and i have in mind
these diagrams you've already referred
to sewell wright's diagrams and you and
your collaborators have built these into
a wonderful tool so these diagrams
represent what let me let you say what
they are
the collection of judgment
about who listens to whom
i'll put an arrow between the barometer
and atmospheric pressure if i think the
barometer listens to
the atmospheric pressure yeah and i will
and i would not put an arrow there
if i think that the barometer uh between
the barometer deflection
and the price of beans in china
tomorrow okay even though there could be
indirect connection between the two
good
so we have in mind a bunch of
facts or a bunch of things in the world
that could take on different values
right the barometer could have different
readings the pressure could be we call
them variables yeah variables right good
but it's a man-made you know variable is
a man-made
entity and then we
we put all of these variables in circles
and we draw arrows connecting ones where
we think that one thing listens to
another thing
okay
and the
as i do have one philosophy question
about the counterfactuals you want to
say you know if they hadn't happened
then b wouldn't happen
um
if all i mean all the robot knows is the
world all it knows is the data right i
mean
what gives us the license to talk about
what would have happened in a different
world where all we have is what did
happen in our world okay
assuming that you are
that you are willing
to make assumptions in the form of who
listens to whom okay when you feed the
robot this collection of assumptions in
terms of a path diagram
and that's enough from now on the robot
can reason counterfactually
because all the knowledge about
counterfactual is contained in the
diagram so the game is to use things we
observe about the world to construct
this kind of diagram telling us what
listens to what and then we can
deduce what would happen
counterfactually absolutely that's the
whole point yeah okay so this is a
parsimonious
representation
of counterfactual of a super
exponentially large number of counter
factors sure
sure yeah and that's something by the
way if you compare it to what
philosophers did
in
about
a closest world semantics yeah like
david lewis right he had the idea that
um a is counterfactual related to b
if b is true in all the
world which are closest to a something
like that right so
as a philosopher he didn't care about
computer representation or
mental representation how would you ever
write down how does the mind represent
all the infinite relationship between
who is closer
which world is closer to which world
given another world okay this is an
enormously large set
but we computer science cannot deal with
super exponential's storage
we it we have we must
first of all as a psychologist
we must agree
that we have to face the problem of
representation
if you have a theory
and the theory
does not allow for policy monitor
presentation
scrap the theory
it cannot work in our mind right
so so
and the other
consideration
is practical
we cannot feed that robot
super exponentially large memory that's
a very good point and you know i guess
as a physicist slash philosopher i i'm
guilty of of thinking like louis
sometimes and just
letting ourselves uh imagine
arbitrarily complicated different
situations but but you're making the
point that if what we care about is
teaching a robot uh our understanding
had better be simple in the sense that
there's only a tiny number of rules and
choices that need to be implemented to
say something about what happens next uh
and something else to
enforce it and
is the fact that we form a consensus
we human being society
we do form a consensus about
counterfactual
how is that possible
if each of our if each of one had a
different notion of which world is
closest to which okay we wouldn't form a
consensus
yeah and it makes me wonder okay so uh
why can we do that i mean much like why
can we talk a language of causality at
all if it's not to be found in physics
and i think that ultimately physics is
where our description of the world
bottoms out
are there special features of physics
that allow us to talk about these ideas
at the higher emergent levels
i am not
i'm not sure i understand what the
question yes
we have to ask why do we what is about
the mechanism and the motion of the
molecules
that makes us believe that the barometer
is the result of that mastectomy and not
the other way around okay
now simon has said in herbert simon i'm
talking about
he had some conjunctions about it he
said it's probably consideration of
power okay
um
energy the sun doesn't care about the
rooster okay and because because of the
enormous difference in mass
in energy involved here right so we we
rather give the
sun
the power of influencing the rooster and
not the other way around so we have all
kind of
time progression is also important right
okay so both time and energy and mass
gives us the
clues
about directionality
good good okay that is very helpful but
now let's uh roll up our sleeves a
little bit and get into the nitty-gritty
uh of how this works um so we have a
diagram we imagine a diagram between all
sorts of different variables and what
listens to what but just because b
listens to a
doesn't necessarily mean that a is the
cause of what's happening in b it's more
subtle than that right
well yeah because b is listening to many
other things right some of them are
influenced by a negatively
so
yeah it's a combination of listening
which for which we have algorithm
that
unpack them
and give you answers to questions on
three level of the listening hierarchy
and that is the
the organization
in which i like to think okay is the
ability to answer questions of a certain
type
so sorry what are the three levels of
the reasoning hierarchy that sounds
important
i thought everybody knows by today okay
well they should all buy your book but
let's assume they haven't yet
[Laughter]
okay the lowest level is statistics
i hope you don't have many artisticians
among your audience because they get
extra extremely
insulted when you put them on the lowest
level i know
yeah
it's just you look at one event
then you infer the likelihood that
another one or cares
will occur or head or care doesn't
matter yeah sure but it's still the
association between events okay this is
correlation this is statistics this is
by the way also machine learning yeah
unfortunately okay or at least 99
of machine learning
so
this is what we get under on the lowest
level for that we don't even need a
diagram
we can do that actually we need it to uh
to um
for parsimonious representation of
conditional probabilities we need a
diagram too but it's a purely statistic
or probabilistic diagram okay we call it
beijing network yeah in my language okay
so that's a level
one
level two is action what if i do that
and the reason it's totally different
than the first one because you're
talking about changing the probability
space
you're talking about a new environment
things have changed in the world
okay i
i don't wait for the sprinkler to be
turned on
i apply my muscle and make sure that the
sprinkler is on so
looking at the sprinkler it says the
sprinkler is on i can infer it must be
summer
but if i turn the sprinkler on i can no
longer
infer it must be
summer yeah
okay so that is a simple example of why
it changes the world
so the world of intervention this is
something that we can learn from
randomized experiments okay
and that was the greatness of fisher
ronald fisher
to introduce a randomized experiment
into statistics
statistic before fischer was all about
correlation
and
that changed the practice of statistics
not the philosophy
because
fisher refused to talk counterfactuals
so he couldn't he he couldn't prove
that his randomized experiment gave you
what you really want you see
what the farmer really wanted
in
his
station in the agricultural environment
there in england
was to know whether to plant use
fertilizer a of fertilizer b
and what will be the yield if i do one
or the other yeah
the father did not care about
randomization okay
so but official convince the community
that if you're randomized you get rid of
all the other factors okay and what you
have is an answer to the farmer
he couldn't prove it
neiman could prove it namely at the time
but he a fisher
locked horn with the name and he refused
to use his notation
so
without the mathematics he was able to
convince the community
that
randomized experiment give you
answer to your question which fertilizer
should they use
good now we are going to a third level
and this is uh
counterfactual
or understanding
or explanation
unit level
retrospection
and the imagination it's the highest
level
of
reasoning
that i i can think of perhaps i'm
missing fourth level
yeah
but um
this is what we mean by
explanation
why things happened the way
and was it
was it the aspirin that removed my
headache or other factors they think as
you mentioned it's event-based
it has to do with individuals
in a situation in a particular situation
one event happened and another one
happened was the first one because of
the other one right and that is not even
in you cannot answer that in a
randomized experiment
right so i guess
the understanding i i'm getting confused
between the second level of action and
the third level of counterfactuals uh
why aren't counterfactuals in the second
level i mean the action is if we did
this what would happen yeah
in the future right there's no
there's no contradiction
there's no contradiction about me
going to take an aspirin now i want to
know if my headache will go away okay
but if i say i did take the aspirin
right my headache did go away what if i
didn't
now i have a contradiction between what
was actually observed event occurred and
one that i hypothesized what if i didn't
take aspirin
good so now i do understand so the
second level is moving forward in time
if i do this what will happen next
whereas the third level lets us go had i
not
done something right how would things be
different right it's i'm doing events
that took place good okay
yeah let's let's look at one of the
classic examples which is always used in
these discussions which is does smoking
cause cancer right this was uh we know
the answer but you know back in the 60s
there was a debate and one of the ideas
was that there were there might be
something else some genetic effect or
something like that that could cause
cancer and the question is how can you
tell
and the answer is you can't
unless you make some no you can't unless
you make experiments sure
you you could but it's it's unethical
and uh
probably practically impossible
to force a guy to
smoke two packs a day even though he's
not inclined to do that
[Laughter]
probably bad yeah
yeah so it's hard to do although
conceptually it's doable
but it's hard it cannot answer the
question without a randomized experiment
but at least we have one technique to
answer it i randomize experiment yeah
yeah you send okay good
at the time
given that we cannot run the randomized
experiment
the answer
is it developed into a fields
in
discussion or controversy an argument
between the
draw tobacco and anti-tobacco they get
camps and
fisher was a heavy smoker and he argued
for
he argued they couldn't you cannot rule
out the possibility that there is a
genetic factor that makes people crave
for nicotine and puts you into a cancer
risk
and indeed we cannot rule it out
except which
can
bring to bear some knowledge
about plausibility in the world
and the way it was resolved is by
thinking
how strong
should that
tobacco gene b
in order to account for the observation
it turned out it had to be quite strong
it had to have a strength that the
uh
the presence or non-presence
of that gene
would make you eight times more likely
to smoke than not smoke okay and that
was just implausible
on the basis of what
that yeah the whole
legal battle there was resolved by
appealing to plausibility well okay
yeah but let's let's put aside uh ethics
and human beings and what we're allowed
to do and things like that and just
wonder intellectually about this
question because it's just a paradigm
for other kinds of questions i mean the
two possibilities are
smoking causes cancer or some genetic
factor causes both smoking and cancer
and if i understand
the move uh that you and your
collaborators want to make it's to say
the difference is that if we force you
to smoke
you will probably get cancer
and therefore it doesn't matter
no
the difference is shown in a model very
nicely you have a model and the
difference will be
in predict the effect of action if i
force you to smoke i can predict the
likelihood of cancer if i force you to
evade smoking to refrain from smoking
then i can predict the likelihood of
cancer under that circumstances okay so
it's a um
however there's another element here
if you believe in if you bring to bear
knowledge in the form of a diagram
then i can do more than that and i can
say
perhaps you should adjust for
gender or just for family history or
just for
addiction in the family okay to prevent
that kind of thing and
so the diagram also tells you
what factors you must adjust for
in order to get an answer without
experiment
so now we are talking about replacing
the experiments which many times cannot
be done
by
a piece of knowledge
that's a diagram a dime contains a piece
of knowledge which is the collection of
who listens to whom okay
and
it tells you now
what factors it should adjust for
if you want to get the answer
replacing the randomized experiment
good and at the level of
this new calculus that you want to talk
about rather than just equal signs we
have arrows now um you invented uh an
operation in this world of diagrams
called the do operator that sort of
implements this idea so tell us what a
do operator is that's a d o as in i'm
going to do it
it is very simple
the operator just simulate on the
diagram
what an action will be in the real world
for instance if i want to say
i turn the sprinkler on
that you can simulate on the diagram
previous right now
the sprinter is enslaved to the climate
to the season because i connected it to
automatic uh controller okay
if i do sprinkler on
i
subject the sprinkler
to a new master that's my muscle
and i
dislodge it from the influence of all
previous influences
i can also i can do it on a diagram i
remove the arrows from his previous
masters and i subject it to the
to a new master which is my muscle
on the diagram and i set the value of
the sprinkler 2 on a boolean one okay
bing
i have a new diagram
i can solve it and that's a dual port a
simple simulation of action i remember
when uh
simon de deo i don't know if you know
simon but he was a previous guest on the
podcast
and uh he mentioned in conversation that
something that he wanted to do was like
uh an implementation of judea pearl's
dew operator and i had never heard of
this concept before but instantly i was
i i had the impression this was
something very very very important
so i ran out and learned about it it's
clear that this is going to be crucial
to how we're thinking about uh
artificial intelligence and and
complicated science questions going
forward i'm very happy with the new
operator yeah
but it's so simple it's so simple that's
good that's not bad
only statisticians get irritated by the
do operator
you know why
because
they realize that they should have
invented it
500 years before
and they didn't
well it's simple
in implementation but there is some
there's something subtle here let me
just sort of say in my own words to see
if i'm right uh you know another example
it's exactly the same structure as what
you've been saying but my favorite
example is
windshield wipers on cars being on and
people having their umbrellas up right
in the data whenever people have their
umbrellas up the windshield wipers are
going on cars and when they're not
they're not uh and so there's a
correlation there in the data and this
is why you say the statisticians you
know this is what they do they go look
there's a correlation but what you're
saying is you can
implement in your diagram
do umbrella
so walk outside on a sunny day and put
up your umbrella and see if all the
windshield wipers start moving on cars
and they don't and that's the sort of
physical implementation of what what you
can do in a bayesian diagram
but this will not convince a
statistician
i tell you why
because the do operator doesn't exist in
probability theory
okay
yeah okay so it's not an operator and
probability
where does where does it exist on the
diagram and where does the diagram come
from
it's a piece of knowledge that is
brought to bear outside the data
exactly no i think that is what a
decision resists
we don't want a new opinion
[Laughter]
well that was a
that was the
manifesto
the
royal statistical society in 1833
okay
we are not going to publish anything
which has to do with opinion okay data
data and only data right yes but it's
not a matter of opinion i mean so i i
think i'm totally on your side here um
but it is not in the data either right
it's it's counterfactual data it's the
question if i walk outside and put on my
umbrella what would happen and and so
you need to go like you say beyond the
data but you can by doing experiments
right
that's one way is by doing experiment
but um
as far as the
windshield fighter yes you can do it by
experiment right right that's it's a
better example than smoking for that
reason we don't have to hurt anybody
by making them smoke
yeah so the station will be happy with
it do experiment and how
explain a little bit how this helps us
tackle
classic conundrums of causality like the
firing squad right you know when you
have a firing squad where there's 10
people shooting at a
death penalty victim and
one bullet hits first
and you say that causes the person to
die
but if your
definition of cause was had that not
happened the effect wouldn't have
happened that's wrong because the next
bullet would have would have come and
hit them right so how does this help us
understand cases like that
that is a difference between
necessary cause
and sufficient cause so we can compute
how
sufficient was
a rifleman rifleman a bullet
as opposed to rifleman 12 bullet
and
that's why we put the squad there
so no one could be blamed
as an individual blame is the necessary
cause
we are saying if it wasn't for your
bullet the guy would be alive
so the
responsibility
is divided here
equally not even equally i think
if you compute it
including all kinds of noises yeah
for instance you are kind of
um happy trigger guys and things like
that
uh the probability will be a
minimal
for each rifleman as a responsible
necessary cause for that for the death
but at least we have a calculus to
compute it that's right the degree to
which your bullet was a necessary cause
for the death
and advice now we can also talk about
sufficient cause
and compute that and the combination of
two plays a role
in responsibility
i it's still not part of a standard
chord procedure
to compute unless they're necessary not
yet not yet but i think when we are
advancing now with the causal ai
i think the
legal
the legal profession will listen to us
because they are dealing with now with
very
critical issue of fairness
to what what degree the algorithm was
unfair to gender to women
or to
minority groups in their requests for
loans and so forth okay so the idea of
responsibility
and sufficient and necessary calls
play a very
critical role they will have to listen
to those philosophical definitions
whereas i call it computer science
definition
yes and listen to them and implement
them in some procedure they already did
because
according to the court of law
the batfall
is
is a
standard criterion
you don't pay compensation unless um
unless you apply the but for criterion
this is
the
the victim would be alive but for the
actions of the defendant and is that
sorry is that compatible with your
definition of causality or do you think
oh absolutely okay but for is no
but for has no meaning in the
uh
colloquial conversations among lawyers
unless you put it in on a firm
scientific basis okay good
and the algorithm is is a definition of
but for it's a necessary cause a degree
to which the action of the defendant
is
necessary for the death of the victim
okay and it has to be greater than 50
according to the court of law
before the guy is declared guilty
but before he's forced to pay
compensation
okay so let me just try to summarize
because i think that we didn't quite
end up with the definition of causality
yet and maybe there isn't one but i
think that no no no i i like it because
i like the fact that we didn't
conclude that because it has different
shades
you have direct cause indirect cause
necessary cause sufficient cause
necessary and sufficient we have they
come with all kind you want to quantify
all those so i'm glad we didn't come up
with a single one well it's not a single
one but but there is a n insight which i
think is crucial and you've said it but
i just want to say it again because you
know sometimes we say lots of things and
it's hard to take away the the message
at least i have this idea that you know
you have this
bayesian network this graph of all the
probabilities of all these things that
can happen and then all these arrows
from one thing to another if if one
thing listens to it i like that
formulation and then there's this extra
statement that you need to go a little
bit beyond the data you have
to say if i put a do on one of the
variables and just force it to do
something without propagating backward
in the graph right without saying why
it's doing that i'm just forcing it to
do it i'm going outside and putting up
my umbrella or turning on my sprinkler
if doing that
causes if that leads to
some effect down the chain then that
action is a cause of those effects yes
correct yeah good
and and one of the and again you said
this again but i just want to sort of
rub it in because it is so profound for
the purposes of learning and robots and
ai
um it's a lesson that the data
or
a comprehensive set of data might not be
enough you have to go play you have to
do some experiments to really learn why
things are happening
and that's where you find
toddler
and babies
constantly playing around in the crib
and they are not
pacified
and they are restless until they get a
state of understanding
why this toy makes noise and this story
doesn't make noise okay
and
that is why this restlessness
is the craving for
establishing the diagram
[Laughter]
so babies in the crib they're drawing
yeah
i'm serious about it yeah maybe in the
crib
are
thriving
to construct a causal diagram
for the crib world
i like that i'm just going to sit in
silence and contemplate that because
they don't know it that but that's what
they're doing just like euclid didn't
know he was no no no i'm sorry they are
born with a craving
okay
that is i'm serious about it which means
it explains why
babies remains are restless regardless
if you reward them
for the right action or not they are
reward neutral and they have this
curiosity
to find out how things work
regardless of the payoff as opposed to
monkeys and other
animals okay which are driven by reward
and not by curiosity
okay so this raises a whole bunch of
questions about at what point in
evolution did we
become motivated to just learn the
causal network rather than just get
rewarded
yeah it's a
i i leave it to anthropology
and i i i leave it but i pose to them
the question in more concrete terms
right
at what point in evolution
did this transitional care or what kind
of computational facilities we we must
we acquired
to enable us to do that kind of things
okay i believe it was the invention of
the counterfactual and if you read like
the first chapter of
the book of why
is the harare hypothesis
that
the artist was able to take to construct
things that have no physical reality it
could not happen in the physical reality
like the lion man
the
head of a person
with a body sorry the body of a person
with a head of a lion put them together
this ability this ability
to construct things which do not exist
in reality yeah
but exist in one's imagination
that was the key
transition cognitive transition a
cognitive revolution it enables the
homo sapiens to dominate the planet
so i will i will mention something that
maybe you uh have not been i have not
heard uh
much earlier in evolution but it
wouldn't be doing what you say it's the
first step toward doing what you say
malcolm mciver who's a neuroscientist at
northwestern was a previous guest on the
show and he studies
fish climbing onto land for the first
time okay and he makes the claim that if
you're under water you're swimming along
at meters per second but you can only
see meters in front of you and all of
the evolutionary optimization is to
react instantly to whatever you see
but when you're on land now you can see
forever now you can see to the horizon
and there's a new modality that opens up
namely seeing something far away
and contemplating different hypothetical
responses to it
you have time to do that and he makes
predictions on the basis of this theory
about the development of brains and
bones and sensory organs in the fish
that they climb on and and i get it i
think that that's you know number one i
don't know if it's true or not i don't
have the qualifications but
in some sense that would be the birth of
imagination but it's only imagination
like within the template of what you
already know is possible uh but you
could see how evolution would
in the long term develop that up into
something much more creative
yeah i can see that i
i haven't heard about this experiment
interesting i'm surprised that fish can
see
outside the water on land
well in fact as soon as they start
peeking up onto land their eyes move the
you know they evolve so their eyes like
you know become frog like right and you
know peek up above their head instead of
being on the side so they can see better
interesting it is it is okay good so
babies constructing bayesian networks
but
again i'm gonna i want to sort of re-ask
a question that came in at the very
beginning but now we're more
sophisticated so we can ask it again um
when we're drawing these arrows uh we do
it on the basis of data even though it's
supposed to be
something that
[Music]
says more than the data are telling us
ideally all we have is the data that we
have to construct them how objective is
that how can we write down
a methodology for saying here's a bunch
of data therefore here are the arrows
you should draw or is that completely
coming in from our judgment or something
like that
is the answer it completely comes from
from our judgment okay however our
judgment has also evolved
in general contains a
condensation
compilation
of
of
ideas
tradition
knowledge that came to us
by social evolution
as well as by biological evolution okay
so
our judgment is also based on stream of
data that took billions of years
to evolve but to to impact us
so indeed
the
controversy
in data science
is whether
we should build an einstein from an
amoeba
by simulating
the stream of data
that
our ancestor had from the time they were
amoebas until they became einstein which
is essentially what data science is
today
let's learn everything from data because
that's all we have all the alternatives
we already ahead
our ancestors worked for us and have
compiled a bunch of knowledge that we
call
a
plausible a plausibility
who listens to whom right okay we have
it already compiled and we know that the
rooster the son does not listen to the
rooster let's use it
both sides have
arguments
on their side
because after all everything we know
originally came from sense data
but the question is can we afford to
wait zillions of years
to replicate it
and
will we ever replicate it the way
we evolved
because
the
knowledge that we have
is subject to
incidents such as meteor
rains
and
annex something we cannot duplicate
anyhow that's a that's a philosophical
question
and i'm for
using
compiled knowledge that we already have
also the argument is like that suppose
you are successful
in
discovering the causal graph okay from
pure data and by the way there is a
bunch of activity called
causal discovery which is based also on
the idea of what should the graph look
like in order to be compatible with the
data yeah let's rule out all the
incompatible i'm leaving it on the side
now it's quite a picked up momentum in
the past few years yeah but aside from
even if you are successful to learn the
causal graph of data you have to learn
it how to use it okay
and that's why it's important to keep it
in mind to know how to use it and to
remember
that you have to communicate with the
human being
the end user
who is enslaved to this structure so you
have to be compatible with the way the
human being has structured his or her
causal graph in order to make to build
trust
between the computer and the user no i
like that because i think that in a lot
of philosophy of science for example
people pretend
that
we should aspire to be some objective
receiver of data and develop hypotheses
but in in fact we carry around with us
models of the world from the start right
the manifest image or whatever you want
to call it and and i i think we under
emphasize the importance of that in
built-in starting point in reasoning
absolutely as i say in one of my chapter
the
physicists write equations but they talk
cause effect in the cafeteria
[Laughter]
very true very true uh speaking of which
i do want to talk about
physics a little bit because
uh well here's how i say it sometimes um
the question that you and your friends
are trying to ask is does smoking cause
cancer or is there some other variable
that causes both smoking and cancer
you're not trying to answer the question
does cancer cause smoking you've decided
ahead of time the cancer doesn't cause
smoking because you know like you said
it's it's heavier whatever we we know
from the structure of the world that
it's plausible that cancer listens to
smoking and it's implausible the other
way around
i i want to derive that though on the
basis of the laws of physics and in
particular like you said that might be
too ambitious as a general rule but i do
want to derive the fact that the causes
come before the effects in time
i want to derive the fact that the
arrows have to point toward the future
are you
optimistic that that is something that
can be derived on the basis of our
physical understanding of the world or
do you think is just going to have to be
taken for granted
you want to derive the time
directionality
from from causes suppose today normally
we think about that causes must be
constrained by the by the flow of time
by temporal precedence no sorry i think
i miss i i misspoke i want to derive the
fact that
causes precede effects from the arrow of
time
but by the arrow of time i mean
the increase of entropy since the big
bang to today
that's the definition of time that's the
arrow of time at the end of time
yes that's right
i i i i don't i cannot help you okay
good i don't know
so it's a nice challenge i can maybe
if you convince me it's worth it worth
doing
yeah i i'll be happy to
immerse myself in that question i i i
need to write
halfway done yeah
but i'm not there
good i mean i know that temple president
constrained the the direction
of cause and effect right but it's not
sufficient it's not sufficient right
well i have been suffering in the in the
rooster crew that it comes before the
sunrise
but still we say it's not a cause that's
right
that's right now that i i completely
agree with um
i'll just add one more claim to that you
can you can think about whether or not
you think it's relevant or not which is
the following that if i know
the
state of the world macroscopically
right now so what i mean by that is i
don't know where every atom is etc but i
know where the people are where the
planets are
i can use or if i even better if i have
a probability distribution
over the macroscopic state of the world
i claim that from that plus the laws of
physics i can predict the probability
distribution in the future
i can just use the laws of physics to
move forward in time but from that in
the laws of physics i can't retro-dick
the past
all by themselves i need an extra
assumption which is the low entropy
boundary condition near the big bang and
i think that's what's going to break the
symmetry between going forward and going
backward that ability to predict the
correct probability distribution of the
world just based on current macroscopic
probability data
okay why do we go to
microscopic but we cannot think too well
you're talking about molecules
and and they're already zillions of them
let's talk about something which is
simpler okay
let's talk about the billiard ball
a billiard table
okay and you have this nice triangle of
the balls sitting there
and what you call this leading ball
that the bounces
what's the name the cue ball
the key of you okay the cue ball comes
it hits the triangle
everybody disperse and come and hits the
walls of the table okay now we run it
backward and take a movie we run it
backward okay
can you tell
can you tell with the bare eye whether
you run the movie forward or backward
yes
but what but you see there's no
entropy here
well that is initial simple f is equal
to m a for every billionth ball
true but you chose to begin with a low
entropy configuration in the triangle
yeah
what makes this why is a triangle a
lower entropy
than the state of the balls uh a second
later where each one of them bounces
which why is it low entropy well you
have i don't think it is it's not course
grading
no it's just the fact that
that you have a name
for the nicely arranged balls when they
are in triangle and you don't have a
name
for their state in a minute later
just a matter of
a name
no i think it's actually
i think there is something objective
about the measure on the space of ways
to be in the triangle versus scattered
around the
just because it's simpler yeah but
if i remember my
thermodynamic correctly
it is not a progression from an ordered
state to a disorder but the natural
escape from
a real
narrow region in
face space to a wider region
exactly yes that's right okay okay so
it's
the order is a subjective perception we
have a name to uh the triangle we don't
have a name for the states through this
state of the balls
a minute later we don't have it just we
have to keep on saying word number one
is it has momentum 23 and so on it
doesn't have a single name
so if we are biased by our language
i don't think it is just our language i
think that it's
there is something about how we observe
the system that lets us coarse grain in
some ways and not others when we say all
the cream is separated from all the
coffee in a cup of coffee
is low entropy versus when they're all
mixed together it's high entropy that's
because we can see the difference pretty
immediately
we are biased immediately yes
okay anyway this is my responsibility to
work further on this i just wondered if
you uh had any strong opinions about it
from the start but uh i want to get back
to the this idea that human beings have
this baked in manifest image because
this is really
where it becomes important for the ai
right i mean the robots don't have any
pre-existing image of the world i just
had gary marcus on the podcast he was
the one who who connected us here and
gary has been very strongly arguing that
there is a
roadblock to deep learning being too
successful if it just does correlations
between different things in the world
you need some structure you need some
common sense
i'm betting that you agree
and causality is going to be part of
that common sense but how do we do it
how do we actually
teach the robot
what the how the arrows go between all
the parts of our little network
okay
let me first answer i agree
not only i agree
but i i have to
supplement it by saying that it is not
an opinion
it's a theorem
okay it's a theorem that here is a limit
there are certain tasks you cannot do
if you don't have this kind of set of
assumptions okay so it is um
mathematical constraints on ability of
robot to do certain tasks
okay now we go to how do we get this
model of the world
into the robot we just
if you have the time
you can just
feed it
with the diagram
plus equip it with the techniques to
enrich the diagram
and reach the diagram by
by
thinking conjecturally
what experiments do i have to conduct in
the future
in order to answer a certain question
what
additional
variables
i wish i could purchase so that i can
observe them
and enrich the diagram
so this is what we mean by automatic
scientists
a scientist that can design the next
experiment
because it answers a question which
currently cannot be answered on the
basis of the existing diagram so the
diagram is
must be
um
vulnerable to
number one refutation
for the data and i'm brought to
enrichment so that that is a
blue sky idea yeah of auto automated
scientists
which i could elaborate on
but
it's all built on
on the
force of
curiosity we must
we strive to obtain
a state of deep understanding
and deep understanding
is having the ability to answer
questions in all three level of the
hierarchy
that gives us a sense of
being in control
and having an understanding of a domain
of crossing the street of playing games
and so on
and i'm not
i don't have any uh
fish in this pan or whatever the
metaphor is here dogs in this fight but
i'm betting that the reaction to that
philosophy from a lot of people who are
working in contemporary deep learning is
no that's not what we do you know we
just let the computer learn everything
it can do all the thought experiments it
can do collect all the data it can and
the computer will figure out what the
patterns are
yeah for that for that we have a theorem
saying impossible
is that someone's name or attached to
that theorem or whose theorem is that
that's the causal hierarchy okay it's a
ladder of causation you cannot go from
level i to level i plus i plus one
unless you have
information or assumptions on level i
plus one or higher okay good but i do
get the impression and again correct me
if i'm wrong that
this
perspective is sort of a plucky minority
in the field it has not swept the
consensus view
it is not swept the machine learning
people okay
or the deep learning people
it's the same way that
it took 20 years to sweep the
statistical society
until they accept the do operator
but okay even that it's still resistant
yeah i still have a island of resistance
there
you'll you'll win i think you'll you'll
win that one i can i can safely predict
i know
but okay i mean even if we're on board
even if we're on the train it does sound
it's really unfair for me
to fight against this huge industry
a huge industry called machine learning
okay because i know that i have
mathematics on my side and they don't
have this certainty so i think it's
unfair i'm gonna win you're gonna win
that's okay it's okay to know you're
gonna win ahead of time there are worse
positions to be in
uh but even if you're going to win it
still leaves us with hard problems about
what to tell the computer i mean what is
the diagram what are the causal
relationships that matter or even what's
the stuff out there in the universe like
do you tell it that there are tables and
chairs in people and cars rather than
letting it learn that i mean how how
advanced is that program of sort of
formalizing our common sense
intuition about the causal structure of
the world okay i haven't
i have neglected to talk about
object
property relationship
i've been very narrowed in what i'm
doing i'm never minded so
i only dealt with code effect
relationship i've neglected many other
things which come into bear
in natural language in vision
interpretation and so on okay but i
think what we have learned
in in the
the causal corner
can be a role model for other areas
okay yeah we have to go from we are now
working with propositional calculus we
have to go to expand it to predicate
calculus all kind of thing that needs to
be done
so
and it will be done eventually yeah we
have to teach the robots about objects
and properties relationship chairs and
tables and their functions
that is i haven't done anything in this
area
but i i want to accept
i mean when you say that just just to be
clear because i think that some people
might hear you say we need to teach the
robot about object property relations
and they'll say well sure but
the important part of that phrase is we
need to teach as opposed to let it
figure it out
we can't wait for it to figure it out
some things we need to teach others
we can let the robot figured out at
least in my corner i have film which
tells us what you can what you must
teach
and what you can let the prog the robot
figure out by itself
i don't have those theorems applied to
natural language and vision
okay and then i guess the final thing i
just wanted to touch on which you've
already brought up but is very
exciting but also confusing to me is the
whole set of applications to
the social sciences and even to law or
moral philosophy right i mean
when we talk about right and wrong blame
and responsibility
uh punishment and reward we're always
assuming some causal structure right you
are responsible for this happening
um
do you expect that a more sophisticated
nuanced idea of how cause and effect
structures work is going to have an
effect downstream on how we think about
these puzzles
yes i have some uh
expectations
some excitements
i can see how we can build the
social intelligence
on top of environment intelligence so
far i was talking about a robot learning
about managing a domain or understanding
a domain
a
disease domain and so on but but now we
can build on top of that the idea that
robots can have a model of another robot
or
all of itself
it can if it has a blueprint of its own
software
then it can reason about
what makes me what made me do what i did
and and then it you can program
compassion of that and saying i
understand why you did what you did
because you're like me
if i were in your situation i would do
the same thing
but are you aware of this and this so
all this relationship awareness
compassion i understand you trust me all
this relationship
involves
a robot having a model of another robot
and once we have it
no
we're going to have a nice conversation
with our
with our apprentice robert
are you optimistic that uh artificial
intelligence will reach human levels of
intelligence at some point
i'm i'm absolutely sure
how can we
how can one be absolutely true on the
basis of conjecture
only on the basis that i don't see any
impediments right
but is it a sooner rather than later
kind of question is this something we
need to kind of contact i refuse to
answer okay fine
no
i i don't have the imagination yeah okay
that other people have okay i'm with you
that's awesome of him
i i don't have it well so you say that
but what you really mean is you have too
much imagination because you can imagine
many different possible things and we
it's hard to tell which is going to be
true right correct yeah
and
and then
okay i'll just close with sort of a
statement that you can you can um
reflect on if you want but
as we were having this conversation i
realized the following weird thing that
i write books i write books for sort of
uh broad audiences on physics and other
things
and over and over again in all of my
books i always start with the following
idea whether or not i like it or not it
just it helps to start with the idea
that there was aristotle
who
imputed
natures and goals to objects in the
world right fire wants to rise up
rocks wanted to fall down it was a
teleological view uh and causes and
effects were front and center he you
know had this taxonomy of cause effect
relationships and i i say we got rid of
all that
galileo and newton came along and we
replaced this
this happens because of that language
with a language of patterns right the
equal sign in your in your mathematical
representation
and that's been very helpful all of
modern physics is this sort of
it doesn't have any direction of time
there's no direction of causality it's
just this is happening and this is
happening and this is happening but of
course like you say in the cafeteria all
we physicists talk about causes and
effects all the time and so it is
crucially important to me
to recover to understand how to recover
our ordinary everyday understanding of
causality and goals and teleology in a
way that is compatible with that
underlying view of fundamental physics
and so i guess all i'm saying is i'm
glad to see you're doing it
yeah i'm not sure i'm capable of
undertaking this major monumental gold
that you mentioned
okay
but i i've i'm having fun
just capturing the way we think
that you and i think and
i i
i have a tremendous satisfaction from
seeing
myself
replicated
amplified on a computer
and i get
i get a
better understanding of myself
well why i had this intuition oh because
i'm so
i have a plague you know for myself
i mean maybe this is a paradigm maybe we
should all have gigantic huge
aspirational goals
and work to make progress on them in
little tiny pieces step by step
i i agree with you
all right that sounds like a wonderful
little lesson for us all uh and a good
place to stop so today at pearl thanks
so much for being on the windscape
podcast
thank you sean
it's great having me having you
having me on youtube
[Music]
you